we have a new PT a calendar everybody we
are coming to you from Antigua super
exciting day today actually because we
crossed a thousand subscribers and a
hundred thousand views in one day I
remember last year we had times when I
couldn't even get a half a thousand
subscribers going to lunch here we are
really exciting it's New Years Eve for
us I don't want to see a magic alive for
us great way to kind of celebrate the
end of the year and I'm excited because
we finish btw how was it right new year
coming up kapiti a calendar in that use
bt calendar hitting every day basically
to keep track of where we are with the
numbers they download it in the link
that will include in this version but
also the reason why I started this was
because habits are important and when
you have positive habit to kick start
your day every day you're much more
likely to fall through and all the other
habits where if you have something that
you skip out on right look if you first
thing the day is you want to go for a
run right and that's the first thing you
want to set your day with and then you
have all these other habits that you
want to continue with what I want
healthy I want to work that what I want
to whatever it is you need to do for the
day what often happens if you skip that
morning run then you're less likely to
follow through on everything else you're
going to eat junkie gonna miss your
workout you're not going to do that call
that you're supposed to do you're not
going to read that book that you're
supposed to read the guy I'm just going
to throw it off and I'll do it other
tomorrow I'll do it the next in reset
where if you do that first thing in the
morning you're much more likely to fall
through and all the habits and I I find
that that very first thing that you do
is the lightning-rod they either sets
you up for success of the day or or
failure and so the idea what the BTA
system was that I want you guys to
invest in yourself invest in your
knowledge come watch a video leave a
comment and when you do that then you're
much more likely to follow through and
all the other successful habits that
will hopefully set you up for the day
and I want to try to help you be that
lightning rod for you
so enjoy the calendar let me know what
you think we're losing the Sun slowly
tears from Antigua have an amazing 2016
continue to believe you look at the
shirt we'll see you soon i neva has a
special message I like it okay bye guys
what's your needler solutions Oh
question resolution while it could be
revolution what's your what's your new
year revolution I like yeah I like it I
like it leave it in the comments will
join the discussion thank you guys back
to see